[Music]
hi
what's your name
you like Elvis Presley
[Applause]
of course who doesn't
one of the kids listening to these days
Bobby Darin Fabian
and you
[Music]
just what is the antenna here Mr
President you got women throwing
themselves at you why my daughter well
sir I happen to be very funny
[Music]
mature than her age
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't have to worry about it
[Applause]
black hair
the more eye makeup
I don't know if I like it
what do you mean you don't know if
you're lying it
like you imagine
[Applause]
[Music]
you know there's a lot of rumors about
you
well is there something you're hiding
I don't have a goddamn thing to hunt
[Music]
I need a woman who understands that
things like this might happen
are you going to be here or not
[Music]
I want a life of my own